"Це ж ненормально", - сумно повторює Маркос Родрігес.
Він розчарований у людях.
Гори бруду. Замість річки тут тепер смердюче болото.
Сміття з кожним днем дедалі більше руйнує природу, домівку Маркоса, його рідну Галісію.
- Дивись, там куріпка. Їй хочеться пити. Я думаю, вона помре.
Людина - це чудовисько. Я виріс на природі, і мені боляче бачити весь цей бруд.
Чому ніхто про це не дбає?
Дитя природи - так називають Маркоса, адже
виріс він у лісі серед вовків. В Іспанії знають його історію.
Коли йому було сім років, він опинився в горах Сьєрра-Морена у вовчій зграї,
де потоваришував із вовченятами.
- Я зайшов до печери з вовченятами і заснув.
Потім туди прийшли їхні батьки.
Я думаю, вони запитали себе: ми повинні його з'їсти чи усиновити?
Він бавиться з нашими дітьми, що ж нам робити?
Я пахнув як вони, я мився брудом, я витирався листям.
Саме цей запах зробив мене одним із них.
Про Маркоса навіть зняли фільм.
Мачуха його била, у батька ж не було коштів на прожиття.
Дитину віддали пастуху, який згодом помер.
Маркос залишився один, полював разом із вовками.
Це відбувалося доти, доки його - 19-річного юнака - не затримала поліція.
Сьогодні Маркосу 72 роки.
Він насилу знову навчився говорити,
але до цивілізації так і не звик.
У нього зовсім небагато друзів, серед них Хосе.
Він працює лісником і поділяє обурення Маркоса
з приводу забруднення довкілля.
- Уся наша робота нанівець. Я почуваюся безсилим,
я відчуваю лють, мені бракує слів.
За численні пожежі в цій місцевості відповідальні саме люди.
Ми говоримо про паліїв. У це важко повірити.
Влада заарештувала кількох підозрюваних.
І тим не менш пожежі стаються знову і знову.
Маркос відчуває жах. Тут не залишилося нічого живого: ні дерева, ні птахів, ні вовків.
- Коли вони все спалять, тут нічого більше не залишиться.
Якщо вони будуть так робити і далі, половина людей зрештою помре.
Коли вмирає природа, все вмирає.
Вона дає нам так багато. Я не розумію, як таке можна допускати.
Маркос за характером боєць.
Попри розчарування він прагне переконати людей, що їм слід захищати природу.
Саме тому він всі останні роки ходить по школах і спілкується з дітьми.
Його головний аргумент - він сам.
- Маркос - прекрасний посередник між природою та людиною.
Він знає тварин краще, ніж людей.
У нього можна багато чого навчитися: повазі до природи, тварин, довкілля.
Це звучить логічно. Коли Маркос щось пояснює,
то це зовсім інше, ніж коли розповідають науковці.
Однак у Маркоса дедалі частіше виникають сумніви,
чи вдається йому переконати людей, із якими він зустрічається.
- Я багато говорю з дітьми про природу, що вона - найкрасивіше, що є на світі,
що ми повинні поводитися з нею дбайливо.
Але чи справді мої розмови щось дають? Не знаю. Людей змінити дуже важко.
У вовків Маркос навчився поважати природу.
Люди ж показали йому, як вони її знищують.
Маркос і досі намагається зрозуміти, хто він у серці - людина чи вовк.